And you know who should be leading that charge?
Feminist. A single mom who has one job,
living in the Midwest. One of her children is under 3.
Is she paying more taxes then the man
who is a major stakeholder in corporate America,
probably living in New York City?
Oh, yes.
Favorite example of this one is Jeff Bezos,
one of the richest guys in the world.
He pays a lower tax rate than a Boston public school teacher.
We need those billionaires paying more
because there are a lot of investments we need to make in America.
The United States is 35th out of the 37 richest nations in the world.
We're 35th in terms of what we spend on childcare.
That's terrible. And I try to push this in Congress.
You know what the first answer is?
Well, we just can't afford it.
The money is just not there.
It's choices. Either the billionaires get a bunch of tax loopholes,
or we make them pay.
And then we use that money to invest in things like childcare
and more housing.
We use it to build an America that works for everybody.